parce que les charrues a déjà la tête
aux pieds
dans ce temps là ça paraît plus lui fera
les démarches à venir vous voir comment
ça se passe tout va bien
comment allez vous j'étais contente de
voir puisque les risques étaient grands
comme ils le disent aimer savait
lui-même se prend au jeu du courage te
prend soin du mans qu'on le verrait
l'infirmière reconnu un résident qui l'a
soignée lors de la dernière éclosion
elle venait de prendre sa retraite quand
la pandémie est débarqué dans les ch et
celle des hoquets bonne journée à tout à
l'heure la partir en laissant des gens
n'a là qu'il faut mourir jeune homme je
ne crois pas je pense que j'aurais pas
survécu à sa bien-aimée admira a pris
soin des aînés pendant 37 ans je suis
habitué à voir a côtoyé la mort mais pas
la mort aussi soudaine pas l'amour aussi
nombreuses vous avez comme les pressions
que vous allez bien tous les jours qui
vous donnaient des soins mode mais faire
là bonjour vous avez tout de même plus
belle pour lui chante olonne n'est pas
un habitué des ch et celle d il les a
découverts durant la première vague
quand elle a vu les malades de la coved
cordée dans une grande salle commune
il a eu un choc déjà ils avaient leur
petite chambre et puis le nom même puis
sont tous ensemble pêle-mêle sans aucune
intimité
ça m'a beaucoup à bouleverser revenir
mais c'était franchement c'était
vraiment comme les entasser ça à
paraître un peu morbide que je dis mais
vraiment je n'arrêtais pas de penser à
ça c'est vraiment con les entasser dans
les cages bestiaux comme dans certaines
moment de notre histoire
cette vision le honte il réfléchit au
sort des aînés dans nos sociétés
modernes et décide de prendre un virage
quand j'ai mis ça je dis non c'est pas
possible il faut que les gens restent
chez eux autant que possible et puis
pour que ça soit fait il faut qu'il est
équipe qui s'occupe de la maison et le
médecin en fait partie petit parti ceci
dit petit parti fait que c'est pour ça
que là j'ai décidé plutôt d'aller en
soins à domicile avec sylvain
aujourd'hui n'est pas là il a été
obligée de s'absenter
les absents sont un cauchemar pour les
gestionnaires comme bernadette c'est
pour cela qu'elle est revenue à aider
plusieurs fois depuis un an
je ne crois pas que les gens imaginent
qu est-ce que c'est de manquer de
personnel pour donner des soins aux
malades
je ne crois pas ça mais ça ça c'est
vraiment c'est une souffrance atroce à
l'infirmière prend à nouveau sa retraite
le 29 décembre dernier
mais le 8 janvier il est encore appelée
en renfort
habituellement c'est son mari qui
conduit bernadette au travail mais il a
failli mourir de l'aco vide en octobre
il est encore trop faible pour
travailler je me souvenais pas du nom de
mes enfants de mon épouse
monsieur jacques qui enseigne au
secondaire introduit lakovic y lui il a
contaminé sa femme et leurs deux grands
enfants
malgré les séquelles il les risques il a
encouragé bernadette retourner au front
en janvier car il sait à quel point ça
peut sauver des vies
on a dit que c'est pas le temps
d'abandonner celle là c'est là qu'il
faut aller b les autres ceux qui sont
dans le besoin
ja prévoit terminer 10ème semaine des
mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai du
tout
l'éclosion ailleurs et qu'on vous
appelle et sera la première oui
le siège à celle des gens de la lande a
été très durement frappée depuis un an
90 décès liés à la coved soit le tiers
des résidents en danger vers la pandémie
a permis à l'urgentologue de reconnecter
avec l'autre dimension de la médecine
juste le fait d'aller les voir discuter
déjà et déjà fait une présence d'abord
puisque par le temps qui courent il n'y
a pas grand présence et puis il y confie
juste ça c'est bénéfique
les pilules le médical c'est gentil mais
c'est pas l'essence 1,2 des soins les
soins c'est s'occuper mais et mais quoi
le médecin fait encore un peu d'urgence
en région éloignée le temps de
développer sa pratique de soins à
domicile pour éviter à trop d'aînés des
lions 6 h et celle des sens les dénigrer
je pense vraiment que c'est maximiser
les options pour pouvoir rester à
domicile et aider en particulier les
aidants
et cette pandémie a transformé que je
n'ai plus peur de la mort oui je fais
attention
d'accord je ne suis pas suicidé mais si
jamais je meurs avec la peau vide
pendant que je travaille
dites vous que je suis moi heureuse pour
[Musique]